o
[Música]
te quiero invitar a que todos nos
situemos en un día soleado precioso día
divino de playa
y de repente entras al agua y está
nadando y está pasándola muy bien
cuando sin darte cuenta
una ola sale de la nada te atrapa y te
sumerges debajo de agua
en ese momento tu corazón comienza a
latir rápidamente te desorientado no
saben en dónde estás no sabes si la luz
está abajo o arriba
de repente abre los ojos y logra ver un
rayo de luz y saca la cabeza del agua
y el instinto inmediatamente te dice
nada hacia tierra nada sea lo seguro
sabías tú que la probabilidad de
sobrevivencia si en ese segundo tomar la
decisión de nadar hacia tierra es muy
baja
imagínate que no es una ola normal la
que te golpea sino que una ola de un
tsunami un tsunami que no viste a venir
de ningún lado que no sabes cómo se hizo
tan grande tan rápido y de dónde salió y
peor no sabes cuánto tiempo va a durar
la fuerza de esa ola que te atrapa
en el mundo de los negocios
los tsunamis existen con cada vez más
frecuencia
los cambios tecnológicos
el acceso a la comunicación la
democratización del comercio
los cambios en el entorno los cambios
regulatorios los cambios climáticos todo
esto sumado forman un constante conjunto
de tsunamis que nos pueden golpear y nos
pueden atrapar y nos pueden hundir
nadar hacia la zona segura
a hacer lo que tu cerebro
tradicionalmente te dice que hagas qué
es lo que estás acostumbrado a pensar te
pone en la zona más compleja en la que
puedes estar
y las probabilidades de morir son
altísimas
tomar la decisión contraria de dejar que
la fuerza te lleve de entender de dónde
viene esta fuerza para dónde va cómo se
origina y que la está causando
y la decisión más compleja que uno puede
tomar en ese momento
pues te quiero contar mi experiencia
personal
en el mundo de los negocios estamos
atrapados en esta constante ola de
tsunamis
personalmente yo participo dentro de la
industria del plástico y nuestra
industria ha tenido que sufrir muchos
embates de distintos tipos que de verdad
nos han dejado desorientados desubicados
sin saber sin saber qué decisión tomar
en ese momento
hace unos años yo estuve de bajo
desarrollo y tenía que tomar una
decisión
buscar nadar hacia tierra y hacer más de
lo mismo que habíamos hecho por tanto
tiempo que no había hecho tan exitosos o
tomar una decisión compleja de dejar que
esas corrientes nos llevarán de entender
los cambios que teníamos que tomar y
cómo teníamos que hacerle frente a esta
situación compleja que ahora había que
vivir día a día
la transformación de un negocio comienza
porque el individuo reconozca y acepte
que no hay nada seguro
que todo lo que tenemos en todo lo que
hemos aprendido no nos garantiza el
éxito del futuro
y allá donde nace el gran concepto de la
innovación
para mí me gusta definir innovación como
la capacidad de generar valor para un
futuro
encontrar esas decisiones que vamos a
tener que tomar a lo largo del tiempo
constantemente de cómo nos vamos a poder
reposicionar para cambiar lo que hoy
somos y para enfrentar los retos del hoy
pero también tratar de anticipar los
retos del futuro
una organización que está haciendo
constantemente abatida por tsunamis no
es una organización tradicional y hoy en
día no hay organización que se salve de
un tsunami si no te ha llegado te
llegará pronto
y los cambios que tienes que dar como
líder son duros
personalmente a mí me tocó vivir
reconocer que el primer gran cambio
tenía que venir de mi entender como esto
nos debe obligar a reestructurar una
organización una organización que tenía
que garantizar que los negocios del hoy
siguieran adelante pero que teníamos que
reinventar los y reposicionar los para
que éstos tuvieran la capacidad de
sobrevivir en el futuro
teníamos que entender que solamente
ocupar el negocio del hoy para generar
valor en el futuro no iba a ser
suficiente y buscar fuentes diversas de
generación de negocios de futuro no era
fácil porque estábamos atrapados en ese
momento en una ola y solamente
sobrevivir era un reto enorme
un líder de hoy tiene que reinventarse
tiene que reposicionar se tiene que
reinventar la manera como los equipos
trabajan tiene que reestructurar la
organización tiene que reparar que el
futuro no se va a construir haciendo más
de lo mismo
entre más grande es una organización el
golpe que recibe también es más grande y
por ende la agilidad del negocio
la capacidad de reposicionarse ágilmente
de tomar decisiones descentralizadas y
de ocupar equipos multidisciplinarios
para hacerle frente a muchos problemas a
la vez son uno de los retos más grandes
que tenemos que enfrentar las
organizaciones
en nuestro caso nos convertimos en una
compañía que nació en el mundo de los
empaques pero que entendió que una de
las corrientes que a futuro estaba
manejando todo este cambio era la
distribución de última miel y en un
período de tres años logramos
posicionarnos de depender de un negocio
tradicional
a un negocio digital del negocio de
donde para de donde se valoran los
activos a un negocio en donde lo que
dependemos es del conocimiento y
netamente el talento esa transformación
de tener que manejar un negocio
de productos y activos a tratar de
convertirte en una organización que
tiene que administrar y gestionar el
talento para a través del conocimiento
generar industrias que generen valor
para el futuro no es una transición
fácil
pero ese es el momento en el que estamos
debajo del agua en el que salimos y solo
tenemos un segundo para respirar y un
segundo para tomar una decisión
me voy a seguir enfocando en hacer más
de lo mismo o me voy a retar y voy a
permitir que las fuerzas que me metieron
debajo de agua me digan para dónde va el
futuro
todo proceso de cambio es difícil
pero no porque estamos sumergidos en una
crisis
debemos de pensar que no podemos cambiar
para crecer
personalmente me gusta no darme por
vencido
reconocer cuando hay que cambiar y
pivotear y tomar decisiones nuevas
para retarnos de como duplicar el tamaño
del valor que generamos
reconociendo que no lo podemos generar
de la manera como lo genera vamos antes
este proceso de tener que transformar el
negocio del hoy para darle vigencia en
el futuro es el primer reto
de la generación de este negocio del
futuro buscar como a través de
herramientas de innovación construir
nuevos negocios
y adicionalmente tener la capacidad y la
apertura de tener un proceso
exploratorio que esté buscando cómo
trabajar de la mano con emprendedores
con otras empresas con competidores con
clientes con consumidores en la
co-creación de negocios de futuro
de la noche a la mañana despertar
y el puesto y el rol que había
desempeñado
quedó obsoleto y ese proceso de
redimensión esa toma de decisión del
líder de una organización es fundamental
para tomar esa decisión
este proceso no es fácil
el libro no está escrito nadie tiene la
respuesta correcta o mal
y lo único que tenemos seguro es que
depende de los líderes tomar la decisión
correcta
o buscamos la innovación como el motor
de la creación de valor futuro
o nos arriesgamos a morir llegando a la
zona segura de nosotros depende
[Música]